depuis plusieurs années le sujet des
violences conjugales est de plus en plus
médiatique si des numéros verts des
sites internet et plusieurs campagnes
médiatiques ont été mises en place le
problème reste bien réelle mais quand on
parle de violence conjugale il est
souvent question de violences faites aux
femmes
pourtant même si ce n'est pas la
majorité des cas dans certains couples
ce sont les hommes qui sont victimes de
la violence des femmes c'est un sujet
qui reste qui reste tabou des cas dont
on parle très rarement car les hommes
ont davantage de mal à parler de cette
situation qui pour beaucoup peut
paraître particulièrement humiliantes
c'est pourtant ce qui est arrivé à
claude père de famille qui durant
plusieurs mois été victimes de la
violence de son épouse psychologiquement
fragile et alcoolique notoire il ya une
espèce de culpabilité à un moment donné
où on se demande aussi ce qu'on aurait
pu faire lors du procès au tribunal de
nanterre la semaine dernière
la procureur a expliqué les nombreuses
blessures observées sur le corps de
claude par les policiers ces lésions
créé moyenne de l'intensité des
violences
et on ne parle pas ici de violences
réciproques le jour où les policiers
sont intervenus
le corps de madame ne présentait aucune
trace contrairement à celui de monsieur
des hommes battus qu'ils ne sont pas si
rare puisqu'il représenterait 28% des
cas de violence conjugale
alors on vient de voir effectivement un
résumé de la situation il y à des hommes
battus et c'est un fait
vous êtes extrêmement courageux d'être
d'être ici avec nous aujourd'hui pascal
g c'est votre histoire a été très très
très douloureuses ou es ce que vous avez
trouvé la force de venir nous parler
eh bien j'ai dû faire deux choses la
première faire une thérapie pendant cinq
ans au pouvoir
comment dire me sentir mieux et j'ai
créé une association baptisée pas battu
et j'ai écouté plusieurs milliers
d'hommes battus avec d'autres membres de
notre association et ça m'a permis de
prendre de la distance avec ma propre
expérience et commençait à parler parce
que ce qu'on entend beaucoup c'est
humiliant pour un homme d'aller raconter
ça comment vous vous l'avez vécu alors
l'homme enfance il a un statut de
virilité extrêmement fort et
et c'est une atteinte au statut de
virilité et les hommes supporte mal à
cette atteinte à leur statut et ça
provoque chez eux souvent des
dépressions graves et des stress post
traumatique et une perte des cimes de
soi très importante ce qu'il fait ce qui
fait qu'ils n'arrivent pas à porter
plainte
seulement 5% des hommes battus porte
à quel moment vous avez été portés plein
de vous parce que vous avez vécu
vraiment des mots des actes de barbarie
on peut le dire oui c'est la torture à
quel moment vous dites il faut que
j'aille porter plainte alors dans un
premier temps mon ex compagne m'a
persuadé que j'étais moi-même
maltraitant parce que je me défende est
alors je suis allé dans une association
pour hommes maltraitance et hommes qui
se sont suivies pour pour mon polar
maltraitance et les deux psychologues
m'ont expliqué que je n'étais pas
maltraitant mes victimes
mais elles m'ont dit qu'en france il n'y
avait aucune structure pour aider les
hommes battus pas de centres
d'hébergement et elles m'ont conseillé
de le quitter mon domicile
et quitte à dormir à la croix de bois
c'est là que je me suis rendu compte que
j'étais victime et ça m'a permis de
remonter un peu la pente et un jour elle
m'a attaqué dans ma chambre avec
l'intention de me tuer on peut le dire
mais j'ai dû me défendre et ça se
manifeste au quotidien c'est alors des
actes d'humiliation alors alors le plus
dur c'est pas les la violence physique
parce que la violence physique
elle tombe de façon régulière mais c'est
pas tous les jours
ce qu'il peut dire c'est le sait le
harcèlement psychologique parce que
c'est tous les jours
tous les jours on vous rabaisse on vous
dit que vous êtes un bon à rien et vous
perdez toute votre confiance en vous et
vous vous mettez à culpabiliser et même
à vous dire que c'est vous le
responsable et qui est la raison
quelque part de vous maltraitez alors il
ya magali qu'ils vont poser une question
vous parlez moi c'était voilà pour vous
dire que votre témoignage et bravo à
vous effectivement c'est très courageux
et en fait j'ai l'impression que votre
témoignage montre qu'aujourd'hui dans
notre société il ya effectivement une
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes parce qu'on parle beaucoup des
femmes quelles sont les etc et on le
sait et mais on oublie les hommes et on
voit que bas effectivement c'est un
cliché l'homme à cet esprit de virilité
donc votre témoignage aujourd'hui prouve
qu'à une vraie différence encore dans
notre société entre les hommes et les
femmes parce qu on est des clichés la
femme doit être faible mais l'homme doit
tenir il doit être fort or ben en fait
on est tous égaux et l'homme est égale à
la femme tout simplement
tout à fait je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous en fait l'homme il a un statut
de virilité qui est synonyme de machisme
de violence et la femme un statut de
victime
alors qu'en réalité il ya des hommes qui
sont victimes
il ya aussi des femmes qui sont
maltraitante et on n'arrive pas à
démonter ce ce phénomène là parce que
les hommes battus en france n'arrive pas
à se faire reconnaître auprès de l'état
on a sonné les cloches de tous les
ministères et personne ne veut nous
entendre ni nous reconnaître sarah alors
déjà avant de vous poser ma question je
vous admire
parce que là vous allez libérer libérer
ces hommes de ce tabou parce que le
chiffre est important dans pour c'est
pour ces personnes-là cd qui mena merci
parce qu'il vous faut un grand courage
pour faire ça bravo mais un succès
incroyable et ma question c'est
existe-t-il un numéro d'urgence pour les
hommes ce qui alors où les femmes alors
mon âge on a un service des malades
ces jours sur 7 on a une dizaine des
coûtants et pour trouver le service
écoute
il suffit simplement de taper sur un
moteur de recherche
soop sommes battus statut amateur et
d'aller dans le menu contact hockey et
là on à la permanence ludivine alors
patache call tout comme tout comme mes
collègues
évidemment je vous admire
ignore ce qui a pu vous être dit par
votre ex compagne au quotidien mais pour
être sur ce plateau pour être devant des
milliers de personnes aujourd'hui vous
avez une belle paire de cojones
croyez-moi je vraiment et moi j'aimerais
j'aimerais qu'on parle ensemble de
choses positives
lapret parce que vous en êtes sortis
vous nous expliquez vous avez fait une
thérapie vous et dès aujourd'hui des
hommes à sortir de cet enfer parce que
ce sont des enfers on le dit clairement
aujourd'hui comment comment vous allez
comment vous avez dans votre situation
de vie votre situation familiale
comment vous vous être construit comment
ça va bah je vais beaucoup mieux
et puis j'ai pilé j'ai pu reprendre une
activité normale pour une compagne j'ai
une nouvelle compagne est ce que vous
êtes amoureuse est heureux oui
ça fait plaisir comme quoi voilà l'art
est possible et sage et sa magnifique
que vous donnez à réutiliser donner le
message de fin d'année voilà justement
j'ai moi c'est ce que j'ai découvert il
ya un slogan que j'ai trouvé c'est une
femme battue sur quatre est un homme
donc ça c'est très important et moi j'ai
envie de vous tendre les bras non pas
pour vous donner des coups mais pour
vous faire un gros câlin et je rajoute
quand on défend aussi les feux les
femmes battues
on a une page facebook qui s'appelle
stop femmes battues merci merci pour
elle